March 1963 the CIA is planning to kill
Fidel Castro using his greatest guilty
pleasure a milkshake the u.s. feared
Castro's anti-american views and
according to Castro's bodyguard
the CIA plotted 638 times to sabotage
him trying things like chemical powder
on his boots a bacteria lined scuba suit
spiked cigars and exploding cigars but
the closest the CIA came to killing
Castro poisoning his chocolate milkshake
at his favorite ice-cream parlor
The Dictator had an obsession with dairy
ice cream milkshakes you name it I mean
it gets hot in Cuba so the CIA convinced
mafia members to carry out the plot the
mobsters delivered a pill containing
poison to a waiter who would slip the
capsule into Castro's milkshake the
waiter placed the pill in the freezer
until the time was right but the pill
froze - the freezers lining and when you
went to pick it up the pill ripped open
spilling poison everywhere so the
would-be assassin waiter abandoned the
plot the mission was a bust
Castro went on to become one of the
world's longest ruling leaders
arrogantly boasting if surviving
assassination attempts were an Olympic
event I would win the gold medal
you